every time a new figure comes along and
you've kept this up when I first met you
you having a George HW Bush got a dad
got a do it and you have kept it up
throughout the years every single
president you've met a fine and I'm
curious I want to start with Trump
you've obviously everyone's doing
everyone's doing Trump in the things you
like to find the rhythm of the eye and
the little takes a little minute many
people excuse me many people excuse me
excuse me many people excuse me excuse
me many you're gonna be happy happy
you're gonna be happy happy like you
know happy you're gonna be excuse me
many people scuse me it's a symphony of
madness aren't you excited you know what
I love too is that he will be married to
a teleprompter but you you were I was
talking to you backstage and I was
saying what is it and you pointed out to
me something I hadn't realizes that
he'll be talking on a teleprompter but
then he'll decide to go off prompter
right in the middle in the middle but
doesn't have much to say on his own
right you still go for it yes yes we're
gonna do a lot in these countries many
people are gonna be very happy and then
he goes to the center you better be
happy happy lined up the Carvey and
he'll go to town yeah did you watch him
did you watch him when you were when he
was in England okay the thing I wonder
what they say when he's not there do
they have pillow talk later on the royal
family you know what do you make of this
millennia no it's just beautiful
beautiful woman very mysterious have
this sort of us still expression no
matter what the circumstances are yes I
know yes
odd isn't it yes you always wonder like
what is it like we all wonder we all
think about it to ourselves what must it
be like to be Melania Trump at 2:00 a.m.
with a marmalade mountain of a man
coming at you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what made me happy about that there's so
many and people call him marmalade or
the orange man or whatever but I like
marmalade mountain of a man coming at
you with carnal intent yes like that
makes my brain happy makes your brain
happen it's like a Beatles lyric yeah
Mountains gonna bomb allayed break it
all cross my hair we're downstairs and
how did you can't sing too much every
notes more three notes more and everyone
has to leave in half yeah I didn't know
we did that many